When you're installing an operating
system, one of the first things you do
is create a partition where you can
store data. But before you can store
data into that partition, you first must
format the partition. That formatting
determines what file system you will use
for that specific partition. This file
system is important because this is the
structure that will be used for all data
that is read and written by this
operating system. And as you use
different operating systems, you'll see
different file systems may be in use for
that OS. Fortunately, there are some
file systems that can be used across
multiple operating systems. For example,
FAT32, NTFS, and XFAT are examples of
file systems that are compatible across
Windows, Linux, and Mac
OS. If you're using Windows, then the
file system that you're probably using
is the NTFS or NT file system. This file
system was effectively an upgrade to
FAT32, the file allocation table 32.
There were a number of new features
added within TFS, including things like
compression, file encryption. You have
quotas, and other management features
built into the file system itself. And
because Windows is so popular, you'll
find NTFS is used across many different
operating systems. Many of these other
oss will read NTFS information. Although
some operating systems are not able to
write NTFS data, but if you're using
modern versions of Linux or Mac OS,
you'll find that you're able to read and
write information to an NTFS
partition. Microsoft is working on the
next generation of file systems with the
resilient file system or REFS. The
resilient file system is effectively an
upgrade to NTFS. And you'll find certain
levels of integration of REFS available
in server 2012 and later. And you'll
find many of the modern Windows desktop
operating systems can provide limited
support for RFS. This is a file system
that is designed not only for desktop
systems but for server environments. For
example, the resilient file system has
huge support requirements for very large
data arrays so that you can support a
huge amount of data in a single
partition. And as the name implies,
there is an emphasis in resiliency. This
operating system is able to repair
itself and it's constantly checking
itself for integrity. You no longer have
to run check disk or similar utilities
just to be sure that your file system is
working properly. There's also some RAID
type functionality built into RIFFS so
that you can build out redundant file
systems with redundant storage. However,
the resilient file system is not widely
installed and you'll see that Microsoft
is continuing with updates and
improvements as time goes
by. A file system that's been around for
a very long time and one that has
supported many different operating
systems is the file allocation table or
FAT. If you were to find a system still
using this today, it's probably running
a more recent version of the file
allocation table, which is FAT32. FAT32
allows you to have volume sizes of 2
terb with a maximum file size of 4 GB in
that partition. But of course, these
days, many of our storage systems are
much larger than 2 TB, which means we
would probably use a different file
system than
FAT32. And if you have a flash drive you
plug into a USB drive, write some data,
and then remove that USB drive, then
you're probably using XFAT. This stands
for extended file allocation table. And
this was created by Microsoft
specifically for flash drive storage.
XFAT allows you to have files much
larger than 4 GB, exceeding the maximum
in FAT32. And this is a file system that
you can use across many different
operating systems. So you can save
something on your flash drive on Windows
and then take it to your Linux or Mac OS
system. Another popular file system you
might run into is ext4. This is the
fourth version or fourth iteration of
the extended file system that you would
commonly find in things like Linux or
Android. So if you're using an Android
portable phone, then you're probably
using ext4.
Linux is used in many data centers and
there's a file system that is
specifically written for the high
performance needed in those types of
environments. This would be the extended
file system or
XFS. This is the file system you would
install in Linux if you were performing
very large data functions, high-speed
processing or anything that needed the
most efficient way to store data. XFS
supports a very large file system size
so we can store massive amounts of data
on these systems. This also includes
journaling which helps minimize any
cases of corruption if any of this
reading or writing of data happens to be
interrupted. XFS also has a minimum
amount of fragmentation. So if you're
writing information to a spinning hard
drive, you're going to have the best
performance reading and writing that
data. Apple also has their own file
system with the Apple file system or
APFS. This was made available in Mac OS
version 10, specifically 10.12.4. And
this is also a file system available in
your iOS and iPad OS devices. This file
system was written to optimize data on
SSDs or solidstate drives. This builds
in encryption, has the ability to
quickly save and restore from a
snapshot, and there is increased data
integrity options within the APFS file
system.